sie alle wollen auf und davon
christine schönbächler und ihr mann
hermann sie ziehen mit ihren kindern
welche und natascha nach kanada anja
kinski und claude wegmann wollen sich in
italien eine existenz aufbauen mit dabei
ist kino der trüffel und anne kuhn und
orlando stamm geben ihrer jungen liebe
ein neues zuhause auf bali bauen sie
eine ferienanlage jennifer wettstein der
mann ali und söhnchen sven versprechen
sich in peru eine bessere zukunft in
lima sollen ihre träume wahr werden
[Musik]
es passiert einem im leben
wahrscheinlich nicht hofft dass man
heimkommt und dabei ein haus betritt in
dem noch niemand wohnt es ist dieser
eine einzigartige augenblick in dem sich
der traum vom neuen zuhause in die
wirklichkeit verwandelt
[Musik]
hermann christine und die kinder haben
eine lange reise von biel nach rostock
im norden kanadas hinter sich und einen
emotionalen abschied
na ja vor allem hermanns mutter
elisabeth fiel das adieu sagen schwer
[Musik]
starke gefühle auch bei orlando stammen
und aniko vor dem abflug nach bali kamen
ihre sechs kinder aus früheren ehen
erstmals an einem ort zusammen
anja kinski und claude wegmann reisten
nach italien
doch anstelle der deutsche vita
erwartete sie dort die italienische
bürokratie und jenny wettstein haben ihr
hab und gut in einen container verpackt
und sind auf der suche nach einem
besseren leben nach peru ausgewandert
[Musik]
die städtischen mit dem noch kritischer
auch eine reise ins glück kann
beschwerlich sein einem langen flug war
eine noch längere autofahrt gefolgt zwei
tage fuhren die schönbächlers von
vancouver nordwärts bis nach rostock um
zu haben was in der schweiz fehlte dafür
ist eine hektare darum das ist das wo
ich dann müsste ich ausgesetzt
das neue zuhause jedoch ist unbeheizt
unmöbliert und die vierjährige natascha
ist krank es ist fertig der bronchitis
wo sie hat oder so dass das konstrukt
selber behandle und und wann es der
musik also ist aber das ist regierten
stimmt dass ich das ist krass problem
mit einem sie weiß nicht dass nicht
notfall nicht
[Musik]
schon am ersten tag in der kanadischen
wildnis bewährt sich christines
erfahrung als gelernte krankenschwester
es ist schon spät am abend im
kanadischen rosewood altes in der stube
der neuankömmlinge endlich warm ist warm
genug dass natascha erschöpft aber
glücklich einschlafen kann
zimmer schlafen das kriegen sie mit ja
und wenn wir den mond bilanz ziehen
sie stiegen die geschenke mit kommen
[Musik]
bestünde das auswandern nur aus dem
ersten schritt wer weiß wie viele
menschen den abschiedsschmerz ertragen
würden
wer sich aber vom neuen verführen lässt
hat es einfacher die auswanderungs
geschichte von anni kuhn und orlando
stammen ist auch eine liebesgeschichte
seit vier jahren sind die ehemalige
hauswirtschaftslehrerin und der
vermessungsingenieur ein paar auf bali
genießen sie vorerst das leben im hotel
ist in wenigen monaten ihre eigene
ferienanlage gebaut sein wird mit dem
namen der palmengarten aber über den
tritt auf dem flugplatz abholen aber
dass ich das problem wo man in zukunft
können leser jetzt immer noch probleme
links war die startzeit
und zwar nur das klatschen
[Musik]
vor einem halben jahr haben die
schweizer ihre erste anzahlung gemacht
um sich das land im kleinen fischerdorf
damit zu erwerben
mehr als zehntausend franken überwiesen
sie auf das konto eines einheimischen
vertrauen inklusive
denn garantie dass es wirklich klappen
würde hatten sie nicht doch seit vier
monaten wird tatsächlich gebaut
erstmals seit monaten besuchen sie ihre
baustelle
als mit dem bau begonnen wurde waren
anni und orlando hier in den ferien
jetzt wohnen sie in bali land kaufen
konnten sie nur dank kommen
er ist die einheimische vertrauensperson
über die alle geschäfte offiziell laufen
klinsmann ja so dass allianz plane das
bremspedal nicht so plane gar nicht
eingeholt denkt ist das wahrscheinlich
in holten die ersten entwürfe der villas
hat orlando selber gemacht die details
ein einheimischer architekt roman und
architekt haben für anni und orlando zur
begrüßung eine überraschung mitgebracht
[Musik]
erstmals erhält das schweizer paar einen
eindruck wie ihr hotel einmal aussehen
wird
die freude im paradies wird jedoch ein
wenig getrübt seit menschengedenken wird
der strand von den fischern genutzt und
die denken nicht daran ihre rechte
abzugeben
und sie spiegeln
enke mit tabu hut kommen
[Musik]
es muss für beide fast wie im märchen
gewesen sein als sich anja und claude
vor drei jahren kennenlernten und
merkten dass sie denselben traum haben
vollmer haube jahr wärme der auch noch
erste führung gemacht haben das ganze
gepäck ist ob auch zu machen sie das mal
überhaupt über alle inneren können
natürlich und damit schwindelfrei ist
also das geht dann als yvonne ich
schlussendlich einmal da jetzt ohne drin
sind das waren wir definierten aus honig
und da soll dann eine heute war nicht
mein star arbeitet mit dem schmiede und
jetzt natürlich gestürzt ist aber das
war von nächste frau sie das gerät wie
willst du die betriebs ökonomen und der
werber träumten von einem leben in
italien
und weil sie herausforderungen lieben
haben sie kein fertighaus gekauft und
stehen jetzt vor einem berg von arbeit
bin handwerklich relativ begabt also mit
relativ gut dass irgendwo muren oder
schweißen oder leitungen unterbrochen da
schon auch die fabrik umbau sicheren
aufwand aber zu schwach war
anja ist wo dann im april label
vorausgesetzt machen vom umgraben nur
ein teil von gar das aus was gemütlicher
suche noch dauern
daneben gemüse kräuter alles mögliche
angebaut aber dafür dieses jahr bestimmt
nur zum teil in china kommt erst vor
einem halben jahr haben sie das gold
erworben hat für einen sechsstelligen
betrag
mehr verraten sie nicht die alleinige
besitzerin und zwar also auf dem papier
weil ich als deutscher eben deutlich
mehr hier kaufen kann in italien als
claude als schweizer doch auch für eine
deutsche die mit einem schweizer ein
agriturismo aufbauen will führt in
italien kein weg vorbei an der
kräftezehrend und bürokratie zum dritten
mal besuchen sie das gemeindehaus noch
immer fehlt klooz aufenthaltsbewilligung
anja war zwar gut eigentlich so also ich
habe jetzt alles verstanden was wir
machen müssen
sie war sehr freundlich also wirklich
optimieren
wir haben jetzt noch ich habe dann
irgendwann auch die größe ausgerichtete
verhungert unserem nachbar und da wusste
ich ja auch dass wir den markt
das ist sehr gefreut und ja also wir
haben jetzt nicht wir müssen jetzt noch
einige dokumente bringen und vor allen
dingen hat sie uns auch gesagt wir
sollen wiederkommen wenn wir tatsächlich
wohnen und wir wollen ja jetzt noch
nicht hier
dass so ein punkt aber wir müssen jetzt
mal verbringen müssen
und das scheint nicht ist eigentlich
nicht schwer
sie spiegeln die säcke mit der volvo
kommen
[Musik]
auch wer sich in ein gemachtes nest
setzen kann muss früher oder später
beweisen dass er selber zu fliegen im
stande ist ali und jenny führen die
elterliche pasta fabrik und ein
restaurant in lima für die
jungunternehmer ist heute ein wichtiger
tag
inzwischen sind die mittel aus der
schweiz in lima eingetroffen
privat geht es den beiden wunderbar doch
das geschäft mit der pasta läuft noch
nicht wie gewünscht
jenny will in der fabrik noch ein paar
arbeiten erledigen und sich da auf das
richtige treffen vorbereiten
ja so wichtig ist schon wenn man
natürlich geld kosten
natürlich pasta basta della nonna so
heißt das unternehmen welches jennys
eltern gegründet haben und zudem auch
dieses restaurant gehört hier ist ali
wettstein der gelernte haustechnik
installateur der chef und er kämpft in
seinem neuen job nicht nur mit der
buchhaltung sondern auch gegen
ungeziefer
sie werden sogar in der post it
[Musik]
nur ein paar kilometer weiter im
stadtteil via el salvador liegt die neu
gebaute fabrik hier hat jenny das sagen
sie muss das geschäft ankurbeln und neue
abnehmer für ihre teigwaren finden
suchen alte kunden dass wir verloren
haben und weiß am anfang wird war dann
fast die einzige haben haben hier
basta gemacht pasta die auch im
restaurant serviert werden soll
doch auch hier fehlen die kunden aber
[Musik]
wie immer auch solid immer aus zwei
zeitpunkt zum tage - muss macht er oft
muss ein anderer in denen das ist so im
museum vorträge wenig hoch können wir
schnell eine runde machen
wir sind ein bisschen im baustelle gar
letztes jahr
wir haben das auch gemacht das war ganz
neues und man sieht es nicht so wenn
schönes bilder mit klimaanlage und habe
das ist schon viel gab seit 25 jahren
stellt janis familie passt daher mit der
vertrag soll neuer schwung ins
unternehmen kommen
und langsam muss
wir führen eine
wenn jetzt bald bauen die trockenraum
hier viel passt das menschlich hier
jedoch dass ein bisschen passt da
die und raum so viele pizzas im moment
wir haben noch das heißt gut dass sie
gut anbieten von zwei maschinen wurde
auch passen und dann mitten in lima das
wiedersehen mit einem kleinen stück
schweizer möbel tradition
unterdessen macht ali im restaurant
kassensturz wenn man rechnet hier zum
konzert
[Musik]
diejenigen aus weniger auf der stelle
jährigen blogger sport und das geld
[Musik]
sie spiegeln
mit erfolg kommen
[Musik]
150 menschen leben in den wäldern rund
um ross wood und seit gestern sind wir
dazu gekommen
der erste tag bricht an und natascha
geht es besser im herbst hatte sich der
förster aus biel zusammen mit seiner
frau hier in kanada nach einem
geeignetem zuhause umgesehen
nachdem klar war dass er in der nähe in
einer wald pracht würde arbeiten können
entschied er sich schnell mit dem
jahrelang gesparten geld machten die
schönbächlers ihren traum wahr für
umgerechnet 250.000 franken kaufen sie
schließlich das haus samt neuen hektaren
umschwung
heute geht's auf einen entdeckungs
rundgang im märchenwald in dem manch
unbekanntes tier hausen soll
[Applaus]
68 weil tritt am bogensport leicht
selbst vorbereitet der staat ist linear
der user hier hätten mit
hier sehen wir daher den tag genau wenn
er wegrennt dass er die schiene holen
oder hier unbedingt zwei stadt gebaut
die die chips dahin will ich noch ein
apostolisches besser gott nicht
letztlich die haare habe die gremien
oder noch nicht aber zum wiesn
ich hoffe nur dass sie
aber es wird schnell klar geworden dass
wir stehen das ist ein franzose
körperlichen rufe drakonische bärische
flagge und trägt sich das internet
braucht
da ist der zug weiterfahren
wir müssen richtig verhalten ihr
gegenüber januar 20.30 gebiet unterwegs
sie probieren das so gut wie möglich
umsetzen
angst machen muss nicht angst - einfach
respekt
[Musik]
natürlich und es gibt sie doch es gibt
sie doch genau der straße die häuser
hier werde ich dafür der dings top
[Musik]
jeden morgen um 5 uhr fahren basis
fischer hinaus aufs meer und kehren
gegen acht zurück das machten schon ihre
väter so und auch ihre großväter doch
früher waren hier die materiellen
schwärmen noch zahlreich die touristen
hingegen selten
heute bleiben die netze der fischer
öfter leer
hallo wie hörst du ich heiße kaputt
meinem großvater gehörte dieses land ich
hoffe du gibst mir einen guten job
natürlich kann ich das schon bevorteilt
wird kann verständigen
doch nicht nur die fischer wollen etwas
von ihm auch orlando ist auf das
wohlwollen der fischer angewiesen es
nicht viele fische zurzeit seit einem
monat ist es schwierig januar gut und
wasser von einem ja wir machen einen
anschluss dass ihr das wasser auf eurer
seite benutzen können
naja sie in unkel headsets land hätte
darüber eigentlich der verblieb und hat
neben abbrecher und hätten aber nach dem
krieg habe sie sowohl das ganze könne
nachahmer rollen und keramik klappte
nach heiraten
wir müssen ihr müsst sagen was sie
verlangen
dann können wir eine lösung finden die
für beide gut ist
[Musik]
in italien haben claude wegmann und an
ihr kind gesucht
anjas schwester nina die
fitnesstrainerin ist angereist
sie ist ein projekt beteiligt und will
zusammen mit den beiden das märchen vom
eigenen landgasthof mit tieren
verwirklichen
lena höhe team ist doch jahrzehntelang
lag das landgut in einem
dornröschenschlaf
und so kämpfen ein werber eine
betriebserkundungen und eine
fitnesstrainerin gemeinsam einen
aussichtslos scheinenden kampf gegen
berge von arbeit
zwei jahre haben sich die drei zeit
gegeben dann sollen hier touristen essen
und übernachten
die armen regenwürmer also haben gestern
bei den aufräumarbeiten diesen brief
gefunden an die seniorin nikolina bar
boni war boni das ist ja die familie die
vorher hier gelebt hat in dem haus und
wir haben diesen brief dann natürlich
geöffnet übrigens datum 1924
das ganze ist eine einladung zu einer
hochzeit von domenico kann uci und
katharina cecchini und die hochzeit fand
statt am 27 november 1924 das natürlich
immer ganz interessant wenn man solche
dinge findet
im haus auch anja und ninas mutter ute
ist zu besuch
ja und da habe ich erst mal die hände
überm kopf zusammen geschlagen was sich
damals vorgenommen haben und habe
gedacht na ja also das ist ja so
ziemlich unmöglich
als ich da oben rum den kletter geben
auf denen bei und dann aber habe ich mir
überlegt wenn man so einen traum hand
und man ist noch nicht zu alt dann
sollen mal den traum zur wirklichkeit
werden lassen somit in essen
während in italien immerhin vier
hungrige mäuler am tisch sitzen ist ali
in peru wieder mal sein einziger gast im
restaurant
diese
bis gut gegangen
jenny ist guter laune sie war bei gate
gourmet einem potenziellen großkunden
für ihre pasta fabrik
ich bin also sitzt yoshi yamauchi mit
roter oder wie sie sind
[Musik]
weil ein paar tassen kaffee aber nicht
reich machen hat jenny heute ihre
produkte beim flugzeug caterer
vorgestellt
[Musik]
viele male hier bekommen zu lassen für
jenny und ali wäre ein abnehmer von
mehreren hundert kilo pasta jeden monat
eine gute starthilfe für ali ist nicht
nur der beruf als wird neu sondern auch
die peruanischen gepflogenheiten in der
doppelten buchführung
[Musik]
was in diesem augenblick weder ali nach
jenny weiß
zu hause wartet noch weiteres ungemach
[Musik]
in kanada ist die familie schönbächler
zum einkaufen unterwegs nach terrors in
die nächste stadt
[Musik]
erstellt
so besticht durch stören
in vielen regionen
die auf 16 die stube
bis die pusteblume
der erste besuch gilt dem laden der
heilsarmee hier ist die auswahl zwar
klein dafür sind die preise entsprechend
niedrig
das abenteuer kanada war für herrmann
und christine nur finanzierbar weil sie
jahrelang auf luxus verzichtet haben
und so gilt heute noch der grundsatz was
machen
ohne ausgaben getätigt zu haben verlässt
die familie den secondhand laden doch
weitergeht die shoppingtour geht das
frohgemut und mit leeren händen
verlassen die schönbächlers ausfiel
das möbelhaus und haben immerhin wieder
was gespart
in bali hingegen rot die rupie
millionenfach anni und orlando rechnen
aus wie viel sie für die einrichtung
ihres ferienresorts ausgeben müssen
275.000 rupien entsprechen rund 30
franken die preise für möbel aus
einheimischem holz sind in bali
verhältnismäßig niedrig dass das billige
daher mit 2,4 planer krause 1 million
wenn man da nicht nur ein liegestuhl
schweizer seen gleichen format von daher
sei man ja liegestuhl das ganze inventar
rim fresser und wille rezeption und zwar
mit gartenanlage und so sehen wir da
kalkulation zur reihe 4 2 siegen
und das in speziellen druck pc ist wie
und der sofort wurden
den ritt ins gewicht fallen da schauen
welche maschine und richter bieten wird
und wirklich sagen wir jetzt abhaken
neben verzehrt
heißt das auch dass man ganz risse oder
geht man da nicht aber es ist so dass
man in der schweiz kann man eine familie
für das für das bayer also das ich
wirklich größenordnung gelte in italien
hat sich glut ein auto gekauft und
seinen fahrstil dem land angepasst
[Musik]
zusammen mit den schwestern anja und
nina besucht er heute das städtchen
camerino die drei wollen sich nicht nur
ein wenig in der neuen umgebung umsehen
sondern auch wichtige einkäufe machen
kraft wir sind die kleinen haben wir da
auch zu verschiedenen und nutzen die
verschiedenen stärken
es ist noch nicht so genau
fashion technisch größer hast dir deinen
über einen chef der französischen straße
ein bisschen lästig anja spricht am
besten italienisch von den dreien und
wenn ein wort fehlt weiß sie sich zu
helfen aber auch claude schlägt sich
durch
man sieht ja aber
wester
die arena mit dem kleinsten
[Musik]
du kannst nicht einfach feststellen
ärger in lima ausgerechnet ali der
haustechnik installateur beklagt einen
rohrbruch in der neuen wohnung der nacht
ich dir jetzt nicht beachtet hier
dritter und kabuki stimmen genau wie
geht immer auch durch gewehr erschießen
auf jackson aufgepasst da muss ich sagte
ja es ist wirklich wie aufs stichwort
erscheint diese aus der unteren wohnung
und sieht sich die bescherung an
das problem lässt sich nicht so leicht
lösen
mit vereinten kräften müssen sie zuerst
die neuen möbel in sicherheit bringen
denn diese hatten zwar die lange reise
im container schiff überstanden
doch jetzt drohen wasserschäden
[Musik]
jetzt ist er wisse sie dass sie ganz
nenne ich habe mich gut bewegt sich gut
ist doch jedes team geführt musikalität
lengerich tvl ihr müsst mit der kfw wird
eine frau müsste der nichtraucher
politische der mitte mit dem finger also
wir müssen mit dem hof das duo twg haus
kriegen organ probiert die möglichkeit
sich der unheilig nicht fertig brachte
richter und erzwingen so
[Musik]
nächste woche bei auf und davon
hermann der förster aus bielefeld in
kanada endlich seinen ersten baum und
trifft auf einen bären
[Musik]
claude und anja kämpfen in italien mit
den tücken italienischer gartengeräte in
bali hat orlando seinen sohn zu besuch
doch leider noch immer keinen strom
[Musik]
genügend strom und viel arbeit hat
harley in peru dazu söhnchen sven und
frau jenny die ihn auf trab halten
dies und mehr nächste woche in der
dritten folge von auf und davon
[Musik]